we're here to talk about the future the
future of video games I'm a better way
to talk about the future video games
than giving games from the past awards
and the King developer conference choice
awards are on this Wednesday nice they
go hand in hand with the IGF where's the
independent games festival awards and
which would also be giving it a bunch of
prizes to video game creators from video
game freighters for video refrigerators
frigerators I thought it would be fun to
go through a bunch of V and nominees and
tell them which ones they should give
okay how about that gave it here either
for the witcher 3 metal gear solid 5
blood-borne a rocket League that's very
close tomorrow yeah yeah well I know
what he's picking we're gonna have our
debate here yeah rockledge everyone you
know like I felt at odds with rocket
League being so high until I actually
started singing time into it right I
feel totally happy that we gave that
number to ya like totally deserved it
that said I would still put metal gear
above it cool fair play what about you
tag I should have pushed harder for
blood-borne even though I at least know
what we got 4th it got 4th okay I felt
like I could have pushed it past rocket
League and then I could have pushed your
metal gear to like to I don't know no
what's sad is that I was yeah only
myself and matt s Pinelli have actually
finished metal gear in this office right
and everyone who talks to me about that
game is so ill-equipped to actually have
a conversation yeah but I'm the same way
when it comes to the witcher right yeah
i haven't finished with your three and
it's and it kills me last year was a
real son of a [ __ ] we trying to
complete those games cuz like for life
or was thrown in there as well so yeah
it was mental yeah we didn't see i mean
i think they'll probably give it i don't
know i feel like i might give it to the
witcher 3 yeah like I go for the witcher
3 but I feel like I've honey I don't
know good because this is like a game
designers yeah Ward's Jeffrey so so
Diego for but then maybe to give us a
kijima that because it's like well you
want to imagine that I doing it because
of the cultural right yeah but that game
had a lot of crazy things put into it
that worked really well so we'll find
out I guess there's someone a couple
more of these Innovation Awards her
story Super Mario maker undertale
splatoon the beginners guys ooh
this is an interesting one for
innovation is I feel like on detail is
an old game done differently my makers a
mario game her story I remember hearing
afterwards that they basically made a
very similar game a couple of years or a
few different people and I'd probably
should look in this myself claiming
anything on here but the word is is that
her story you know it came after a few
other games the same crater used very
similar tricks within the narrative so
if point not be as innovative as there
perhaps not yeah we should look into
well here we yeah we're not hearsay oh
yeah splatoon which is a duck that's
innovative in many ways and the
beginner's guide which anybody
innovative interesting it met loads of
different ways i'm not sure i call it
innovative necessarily would hang up i
would give it to mario maker yeah yeah i
think it's the first game that really
made like creation the the number one
thing and then like gameplay was number
two but even then gameplay is like still
so great mhm it's it's kind of hard to
match and but creation and making
communities out of it is something that
hasn't really been mean maybe in pc
world that that happens or things like
counter-strike and team fortress but
right but mario maker it opens the doors
for like really crazy things and it is
still going strong and intended was
still adding things to it i know that's
not all innovation but at the same way
they definitely found a thing that
worked yeah they struck gold that no
one's ever done it before they go dead
eat it best visual art or in the blind
forest the witcher 3 star wars
battlefront blood-borne splatoon i would
give it to blood-borne personally
scotland blown i or ii yeah are re yeah
already beautiful or he's great looking
at yeah yeah very pretty LeBron yeah
that I battlefront that game the best
part of that games and looks and sounds
yeah and it's also an audio along with
oriental by forest everybody's gone to
the rapture malgor saw 25 encrypt the
necrodancer i love the thoughts in there
that's crazy any takers on that one I'm
not gonna go to bat for Metal Gear oh
there's one thing in that game
love so yeah Wyatt humming in your ear
yeah the effect of having your partner
hum in your ear and having this really
subtle companionship that's sort of like
it yeah man it becomes real and you
don't even realize it it's like the
subconscious thing that you develop mmm
it's not there you're like wait a minute
wait wait something's missing what is
that then you realize what had happened
the whole time that's awesome I guess
the last one will look out here on the
GDC awards best narrative her story The
Witcher 3 like the strange undertale the
beginners guys again sounds to me like
the witch edge here Witcher for me is
what I think probably and then I've not
competed like the strange so care what
you say well there you go
congratulations to all the winners that
we just named congratulate yes exactly
that's hope they get them right at the
awards show congratulations to all the
nominees but while we're here let's have
a look at the 2016 independent game
festival finalists this is always very
interesting because I member for years
you wouldn't know any of these games
yeah and then you kind of know a couple
of them and now I feel like I know most
of them every year when they comment
like the Sheamus recanati grand prize is
between darkest dungeon her story keep
talking and nobody explodes mini Metro
super hot and undertail all games that
I've played a decent amount of yeah so I
don't know what would you go for the
grand prize mmm that's tough because the
games are so different yeah darkest
dungeon her story yeah well bomb defuse
okay bomb defusal game and mini Metro
like mini Metro so good is it that's the
the one where you're like you're
basically making it's like a London Tube
map as well looks like or like a subway
map and you're basically just lining
things up it sounds great it's it's like
a really basic version of fact Oreos
that's really good keep talking nobody
explodes it's really interesting the way
it integrates just the physical with the
virtual mmm like I would that was the
first one we wanted to say so yeah I'm
gonna go with that I saw one read it as
well that it sold 200,000 units I
believe it yeah that's really incredible
yeah look at this that what a great game
like it okay maybe doesn't look too
great looking this thing right here haha
absolutely exhilarating for those on the
podcast version there are two gentlemen
with beards sitting across from each
other at a coffee table one of which is
reading a book but yes super fun it's on
oculus but obviously you can just play
normal last PC as well yeah and like you
think you can like cooperate with people
like I wouldn't be trying to do they
like so looks like a horn like what kind
of warned you know like I don't know
just a horn like it's increase arguments
when there shouldn't be because a [ __ ]
like the instrument or like but it
instills like really good tension and
it's just really exciting it's fun to
play with people like who don't play
games yeah yeah aptitude for gaming
whatsoever it's super fun excellence in
visual art this work week into a little
bit obscure games are Morello darkest
endren mini Metro oxen free panoramic o
and G nog don't watching August
panoramic all I believe is that very
trippy looking game and I wonder how
much of that is orchestrated versus
generated right if you understand what
I'm saying yeah belvane sting can we
give and we give no man's sky some props
for all the beautiful graphics when it's
just made up by an algorithm it's all
pastels no I know art no no I know
artists behind it is it really hard no
waiver Awards this is actually I'm not
gonna go into that wonder position to
OVO nuovo is a tie it was our mellow
mellow I'm her hello Amarillo I want to
sort of give shoutouts to these games
sibel which Sybil Sybil I think it's
Bell Sibella God mr. jobs have fantastic
contraption her story keep talking
nobody explodes or kids to dusk
panoramica progress and the beginner's
guide I believe that section sort of
highlights games that are doing
something new and interesting mostly so
I think people should check out those
games we just listed it just for the
sake of like looking at what's out there
cuz that's one of the most interesting
parts of this award and also to that
point best student game a pouch be
glitched chanbara hopefully not
onii-chan but no circuit infinity
orchids to dusk and a pitfall planish
all games oh my god what's happening
here there's a video game there's Nina
Freeman of course accessible that is
Nina's game I saw her outside the office
Bush two hours ago and then excellence
in design that status for the last one
her story in finna factory keep talking
Oh explodes Kingdom mini Metro and super
hot super hot
mmm Michael keep talking again super hot
yeah there was a lot of the same games
on all that there is honestly I'm just
saying I wouldn't be surprised if
someone goes home a multi-award winner
that's what happened with what was this
we had two years ago we were backstage
and we had the name I asked you this
earlier it was the game you papers
please nice game Wacom you guys played a
crap ton of games come right like you
got totally into it that's right it's a
great video game great view again anyway
so they go congratulations to all the
nominees for the GDC on IGF awards best
of luck tomorrow and I hope what we said
wins because it'll make us feel good in
our bellies let us know what you think
should win in the comments below